good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday hope
everyone had an amazing stellar in club
weekend we did we really did we did so
much this weekend i can't believe it's a
monday i feel so off kilter probably
because we went to a concert last night
we got home at like midnight and now
it's just monday so crazy it's so gloomy
here in new york which is reminding me
of one of the movies that we watch this
weekend called a rainy day in new york
it was like a young adult woody allen
film it was really good it had your fave
timothy chalamet who
played won me over played the part to a
t yeah you know i've not
i think i've spoken a lot about how i
literally don't understand how timothy
chalamet is famous but after seeing that
film
stellar he has some chops and elle
fanning and selena gomez and it was just
really great and so now every time it
rains in new york i think i'm going to
be thinking about that movie and it does
have a certain sequoia when
so i'm sitting here thinking like my
throat is like a little scratchy i'm
like oh my god like i have covered her
strap then i realized on friday night i
was out till three in the morning doing
uh karaoke and then last night i was
screaming the top of my lungs at one
republic concert so i think it's fair to
say i'm totally fine
sure i just have you know like this is
what happens to singers ugh
yeah that's the truth ain't that the
truth don't i know it yeah i know i know
it
no but last name was the first big
concert that i've been to since covid
and you couldn't ask for a better lineup
need to breathe and then one republic
unfortunately we're we were being too
fat to enjoy most of need to breathe
because we were just shoving our faces
with like and i just thought i thought
we had more time like yeah we just were
being fat and we missed some of the
really great songs but when we did it
no regrets i was so hungry oh i have
many regrets because then we had like
the intermission in between and we kind
of eaten them yeah um so we missed some
of the good songs but you could just
tell they were putting on an amazing
show gorgeous gorgeous band i had no
idea need to breathe was a christian
rock band and then when we got to our
seats and we started like singing the
gospel songs i was like i feel like i'm
at church and margaret was like yeah
they're literally like a church band who
got famous and that makes a lot of sense
because i felt like i was at hillsong
plus as ryan tedder said like pnc bank
arts center in holmdale is the new
jersey temple and when you're there like
everything feels like you're in church
it's really a spiritual experience and
it's so random but it's really i think
my favorite venue that i've ever been to
and i seek out concerts at pnc bank arts
center amphitheater in new jersey and
i'm sure every place has your local
amphitheater and it's incredible for you
but this is our amphitheater in the
tri-state area and it's in crayon and we
have like a niche tasted music so like a
lot of times especially when it comes so
not like other girls no like we can't
just like turn on the radio like we
we are not like other musicians
so for us like the people we want to see
in concert never [ __ ] play in new
york city proper or like even remotely
close so usually women want to see a
country artist or like a band that's
like not so mainstream we have to go to
new jersey which is fine because new
jersey's a gorgeous state i'm heading
actually to new jersey um for some some
shows um but that's i have a list of
things to talk about we're not there yet
okay let's keep talking about the one
republic concert which was really a
religious experience it was so
good i don't i haven't seen um one
republican concert ever was that your
first time that was my first time as
well they were so good and they are for
everyone like
so many
ages of people there yesterday like
everyone was enjoying like it's a
family-friendly event except there was a
lot of really young people too and i was
like who knew yeah they were like
tailgating outside i was surprised i
thought it would be an older crowd also
yeah i thought it would be like more
people our age but there was a lot of
really young kids but i also think like
an amphitheater on a sunday is just a
good time for them and everybody can get
down to one republic and they're just so
talented
and it was really i bet you know what
i'm just not the same girl that i was i
know like i
i used to not get tired until it was all
said and done i was like damn that was
an experience but i was like so fatigued
in the middle of the concert me and
jackie like looked at each other and we
were like not okay like my legs were
killing me
walking i was like i am not built for
this my aura ring was off the charts
right she was like girl take a seat i
slept so deep i was like that that
amphitheater happens to be like
obscenely large with so many steps it's
so unnecessary um so once we got back in
the car like i was fully dehydrated my
lips were so chapped i got home i took a
shower and drank like four bottles of
water i'm still not okay yeah no and
waking up this morning now it's just
like monday we have the whole week ahead
of us i'm glad that we had the
experience
but
it took so much out of me well this is
your last week in new york and we have
to do the most so by the time you get
to your new home like you're going to be
exhausted
so it doesn't stop i don't know if you
forgot that we have plans tonight i know
i remembered i was actually gonna text
you cause i remember you asked me my
availability for tonight can i wear
something like this yeah i'm blogging
the whole experience for the patreon
it's gonna be um
it's gonna be
while we've got a lot of vlogs going at
once right now because we're also doing
like a last week's new york tings vlog
where we're doing everything special and
like i did have to go back to pnc bank
arts center one last time before i left
the city yeah knowing just for my life
because i've had so many amazing
memories there yeah no it was it was a
great way to say goodbye
it was it was really emotional honestly
like between the one republic songs just
you know the undercurrent of what was
really going on with our group you know
like jackie's last concert in new york
was anybody even thinking that i think
we were all just like so hot and sweaty
oh no i was thinking that because i
didn't even really i mean i feel like
whenever there's going to be like a good
show in new york i will come back for it
yeah no i mean but i was definitely
thinking last night like this is because
at like five o'clock i was like are we
really going to a concert like no shade
to one republic but like i'm tired um
and if it weren't for it being your last
soiree i would have stayed my [ __ ]
yeah probably same for me but i'm glad
that we went me too it was amazing and
that's always what happens like i never
want to go anywhere you know but i'm
always glad that i do most of the time
most of the time so anyways if one
republican and need to breathe they're
coming to your town go and get there in
time for need to breathe get your snacks
in between need to breathe in one
republic so that you don't miss
incredible songs in crayon songs learn
from our mistakes yeah um so that was
great
and i have a couple things i need to say
the second thing is that on we have a
show on friday so i haven't been able to
like really you know brag and i just
want to let everyone know i'm like
re-entering my annoying promotional era
okay we got a couple months off because
i haven't been on tour since may but i'm
going back on tour um so the annoying
girly is back west not west bank i was
gonna say
west hampton or red bank i'm going to
the west bank
west hampton new york red bank new
jersey and new haven connecticut the
first three shows of the final leg of
end log are on sale now so you can get
tickets to those three shows at
girlwithnojob.com tour tri-state area
i'm coming back i'm also hitting a bunch
of other places but these are the first
three shows that have tickets they're in
august there's summer shows we're gonna
have great weekends in the hamptons so
we just want everyone to get their
tickets when's your west hampton show
august 12th because i found out last
night that you are sandwiched in between
at the west hampton comedy
enterprise performing arts center west
hampton comedy performing arts center
like she's performing in between on
different days in between tom segura and
tim dillon jackie's i think i need to
make a trip my three favorite comedians
i need to make a trip just for it and
i'll stay in west ham for a few days and
just keep hitting up the performing arts
center i think that you know the
performing arts center of west hampton
clearly respects podcasts clearly and
you know what it is it's a claudia
sandwich
literally
[Laughter]
so girlsnojob.com tour tickets available
don't miss out don't be a loser yes it
is the same material from the tour that
was at the beginning of the year we just
took the summer off um so if you haven't
seen it yet like really it would be your
loss like not to toot my own horn but
like it's
pretty like life-changing honestly i
think it's pretty in crayons it's
included yeah so that was the first
thing i wanted to say on my list oh the
second thing i wanted to say is all
weekend i've been catching up on
rupaul's drag race and i just want to
give like a really brief um recap on
what my thoughts are because the finale
like is coming up soon so it's all stars
all winners so people who have won
different seasons now coming together
it's like what they always want to do
you know for housewives all stars but
they finally did all stars all winners
and it wasn't really like fully obsessed
with every single person that they
cast but i was wrong as i usually am and
hear my thoughts because they're i'm
just going to go through each person and
tell you what i mean and just you don't
want to save your thoughts for like a tv
recap at the end no because we have
unburdened yourselves so like it really
wouldn't make sense you know okay and
it's like fresh on my mind i was
watching it four seconds before i got
here okay okay we'll let you do your
thing so monet exchange is the first
time i list and i just want to say i do
like that they're doing no eliminations
because it's a different way you know
everyone gets to give it their all and
then at the end we decide but monet
exchange is just kind of lackluster and
i don't think she's really keeping up
with a lot of the girls so if someone
were to be eliminated i do think it
would be her shay coulee is my queen i
rooted for her on her season and then
when she won all stars like i was just
really overwhelmed and i'm sad to say
that she is kind of fading into the
background of the season and she's even
said that in some of her confessionals
so i just don't really know like what's
going on with shae but i don't think
she's gonna win whereas before like i
would have went into the season being
like shay coulee is gonna win and i will
be rooting for her but then you would
have been wrong because right because
never accurately predicted never
accurately predict because that's the
thing about rupaul's dragon tell me the
rundown and then i'm going to predict
who wins okay evie oddly is not my
favorite it's just like not my
particular type of drag she's very like
alt you know she does like she's not
like others she's not she really isn't
she's more artsy like dark and that's
just i'm much more into like the glamour
of drag but she's really smart in her
drag so like i'm happy for her but not
my particular favorite raja is also
someone um who i would loop in with
monet in just the sense that like
they're not keeping up with the other
girls you know they're just they're
really good but like this this cast is
is beyond talented and i just don't
think either of them are gonna make it
jada essence hall really good really
strong saw her twice at rupaul's drag
review in vegas but i don't think she's
gonna win even though she's currently in
the lead i'm i'm a few episodes behind
she's currently in the lead but i don't
think she's gonna win
um
who else is on this
oh the vivian
one rupaul's drag race uk so i've never
seen it and she won the first season so
it was like a really big deal that she
came on an american show and she's
[ __ ] hilarious like you would love
her her accents are so good she's like
everything is royal like she makes she
makes being british like her personality
and it's so good she's not really like
winning she hasn't won a lot of
challenges but she's so talented she
keeps getting blocked she's so good
jinx
when jinx monsoon won her season i was
so confused i was like i really don't
get it i fully understand it now i am
rooting for jinx monsoon like
it's nobody's business everyone keeps
blocking her because they know she's
gonna win she's so smart she's so talent
she's [ __ ] hilarious jinx is
everything of the sort so is trinity the
tuck who honestly i wasn't that familiar
with trinity is everything i think
trinity could win the way that like she
won the design challenge while also
helping all the other girls so because a
lot of them don't know how to sew for
the design dress choose the blue dress
yes oh my god jackie came to my house
for five seconds and watched me last
night yes so she is everything she's so
funny i'm rooting for trinity and jinx
that's where else that's
those are my thoughts and i'm sticking
to them
based on what i saw in the five seconds
that i watched and i think i only saw
two queens i think shea coulee is going
to win okay i mean that's all something
wonderful when they had that design yeah
she had um they had to reimagine some of
rupaul's iconic looks and make them
their own like from scratch and she took
this big leopard dress that reward and
made it into like this sickening
other thing like it was amazing yeah no
she understood the assignment okay i'm
rooting for jinx monsoon
and so we'll just have to say we shall
see we'll see him on soon enough will
keep us posted of course then the last
thing on my list was actually i think
that was it okay yeah
so do you think without further ado we
could jump right in it feels so
it feels kind of soon considering we had
a long weekend but
i guess that's pretty much everything we
hung out with each other we watched
movies we had like a really nice time
yeah no i'm definitely not done because
i spent like literally so much time with
rolled and obviously everyone couldn't
look at me now like i look so different
because i'm literally like
a different person yeah it was just
amazing like i'm really um there's like
a twinge of sadness now when i hang out
with rolls yeah because it's just like
get all the kisses in get all the kisses
in before his mother kidnaps him
does it have your ovaries tingling no
because honestly i doubt that there is a
child i could create that i would love
more than rolled honestly honestly the
fact that roll did not come from my
loins like shocks me every time i see
him that's so sweet that's literally my
child just so you know that's how i used
to feel about theo oh
my god that's like even when kayla was
born i'm like how am i gonna love a baby
more than i love theo and then of course
i did and then even when um no it
literally goes like theo kaler like we
keep one upping ourselves you keep like
the heart just keeps expanding and
contracting and i believe that there's
room in everyone's hearts for more
people yeah but literally rolled is my
whole heart and
he's
literally obsessed with me like it's
yeah it's kind of toxic yeah no because
he loves entertainment and you're so
entertaining because i'm i'm literally
an entertainer you are that's what i do
for a living he couldn't have a better
auntie he he could not have a better
auntie like he loves singing he loves
comedy loves dancing he loves theatrics
he was respect for thespians like
i literally am his favorite person on
the planet and i'm happy for him that he
has me honestly and i'm happy for me
that i have him it's really mutually
beneficial relationship it is it's
really sweet um and we started sleep
training last week which i spoke a
little bit about on breaking bread i
think which by the way new episode is up
and it's really funny it's called um big
flop energy of course we were just being
like psychotic it was it had been a long
day so we both just sat down at the mic
and just let it rip let it rip let it
rip it's on spotify now if you weren't
able to catch it live on wednesday but
sleep training has it was tough at first
as they said yes but it has borne fruit
and it's wonderful so good it's really
we're in a whole new place and it's
really great so i'm happy to report what
do you say to the mamas who like
how are having trouble with sleep
training because like those first two
nights like when they're crying you
obviously just want to like get in there
and make everything okay yeah well there
really is a difference between like a
cry and like a distressed cry right and
if you have like a camera or a baby
monitor and you can see that like
they're mostly whining not like
screaming crying something's bothering
me right and sometimes i like cry so
much and i'm like oh okay maybe
something is bothering you so i'll check
are you wet did you spit up here and
sniff the butt
i know like the last time you ate like
you i know whether or not you might be
hungry so if you know it's just those
whiny cries like you just have to push
through it is it's what's best for them
too because they need to learn how to
fall asleep on their own it's not fair
if they don't know but it tugs at the
heartstrings yes it does it's very it's
very hard but it's worth it i watch
every night i turn into my camera my um
division my world division it's my k
vision i have both sets of nieces and
nephews on my camera and when that clock
strikes it's like eight o'clock i'm
fully tuned in yeah it's literally the
best tv on the planet it's nibbling
vision and it's so interesting how
different they are like kayla's like
finally get me away from my parents i
need to sleep i'm exhausted literally
putting this family on my back all day
i'm exhausted harry is like what is
sleep i refuse to not be awake what if
the family needs me um and it's probably
one of my favorite things to watch
honestly sound on yeah just like drag
race totally sometimes you know i notice
how you know at first
with the shapiro's and at first with you
you know they leave the microphone on
and i abuse the privilege i get in there
when they're trying to sleep and i'm
like go to bed kayla
and then suddenly i realized like
they've removed that feature from my
account which is super [ __ ] up and not
fair to the kids but whatever
yeah you know you got to do what you got
to do i can't get on the microphone
anymore which is just it ain't right
i've been was i silent or silenced
silenced silenced for sure she's
silenced by my sisters for sure
disgusting for sure
okay now without further ado because we
do have a quite a bit to talk about
today but it is time for the pacifier
stories that you yes you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
who needs to know
you got it okay not you
you
today's episode is brought to you by
blue nile jewelry so if you are getting
ready to pop the question you're getting
ready for someone else to pop the
question to you check out bluenile.com
it is the modern convenience of online
shopping for fine jewelry that's as
unique as you are so if you're hoping to
get engaged soon and you want to forward
this episode to your man now would be
the right time because blue nile
is the way to go so you can create the
engagement
ring of her or his dream they have
simple online tools that let you choose
the diamond shape size and clarity as
well as the setting style so they have
jewelers that will hand craft the
perfect engagement ring and each ring is
one of a kind you can trust blue nile
they have a ton of history and
credibility they are the original online
jeweler since 1999 they have helped
couples create the perfect engagement
ring they are also committed to ensuring
that the highest ethical standards are
observed when sourcing diamonds so they
value handcrafted quality they have
legendary services like expert advice 24
7.
when you commit to a piece blue nile
does too they have guaranteed service
and repair for life you also have peace
of mind knowing that if it's not perfect
it's no problem because they have 100
satisfaction guarantee you can shop
stress free with guaranteed free
shipping and returns and if you need
your purchase fast in most cases blue
nile can deliver overnight so if your
man's is like you know procrastinating
or
you know you just decide like i have to
do this tomorrow
wake up and you're ready to get engaged
it's so true but that's actually how it
happens and so blue nile will get it
there for you most times overnight so
every order is insured and it arrives in
discrete packaging that won't give away
what's inside which is super helpful by
the way so you can make your moments
sparkle with jewelry from bluenile.com
and going on now
is the blue nile anniversary sale you
can save up to 40 on classic fine
jewelry pieces and 25
on engagement ring settings plus every
order is insured ships free and arrives
in discreet packaging so you can shop
stress fee free and find your forever
piece at bluenile.com today the
anniversary sale is happening now at
blue nile nile dot com today
great okay our first story is the big
story of the day jlo and ben affleck are
married she confirmed it in her july 17
edition of on the jlo newsletter she is
loving her newsletter she said quote we
did it love is beautiful love is kind
and it turns out love is patient 20
years patient she called the vegas
ceremony exactly what we wanted and
detailed their trip down the aisle she
said quote last night we flew to vegas
stood in line for a license with four
other couples all making the same
journey to the wedding capital of the
world imagine being one of those couples
like
just getting married in vegas you know
wanting to elope you walk into the thing
the chapel and jaylon ben affleck there
like would you let them cut
yeah cause then you could witness theirs
you know that's an interesting question
about cutting like when it comes to like
celebrities like if i was in line at
like a concert for the bathroom for so
long and then like miley cyrus comes in
and i was like can i cut
i think she probably wouldn't ask she'd
be escorted by security who cuts the
line for her yeah no but some people
would see mine and be like oh my god cut
me but i don't think that you would be
that person
no i guess i mean if it was taylor swift
it depends who the celebrity is yeah
yeah
back to the story behind us two men held
hands and held each other in front of us
a young couple who made the three-hour
drive from victorville on their
daughter's second birthday all of us
wanting the same thing for the world to
recognize us as partners and to declare
our love to the world through the
ancient and nearly verse nearly
universal symbol of marriage like why
does she have to write it like a poem i
just want to say like i don't really
hear jayla's voice it's giving ghost
writer no it's just giving like
a
she needs to fill the content of the
newsletter so she's being wordy like
she's reaching her word limit she's
reaching her word count for sure
okay newsletter aside and this chunk of
words aside they got married in vegas
this weekend
spur of the moment they didn't want a
spectacle you know they clearly planned
it because like there was glam and chris
appleton was there doing her hair there
was a versace dress like right but it
wasn't you know what you would have
expected from jlo and men what do you
think well you know i actually really
like this and let me tell you why even
though usually i'm like when celebrities
do things low budget i'm like girly why
you're literally the only people person
with the budget so go balls to the wall
but i do think in a sense first of all
they've both had big celebrity weddings
and i don't think um
i think they're probably more fun less
fun than they look
and when it comes to jlo like she was
just recently engaged and i know that
her and a-rod like were planning this
like extravaganza in positano and it's
probably like
traumatizing and it just like kind of
ruins
the love wedding planning is horrible
yes so and i'm sure on that scale it's
even worse even though you have so many
people doing things for you the stakes
are so much higher and everyone has
something to say about your dress and
flowers so i kind of love this i don't
know if this means that they're not
going to do an official wedding but i do
kind of love this and it also reminds me
like i thought travis and courtney were
having a big blowout in l.a after their
italy wedding but it's maybe they don't
but he also got sick right right
so here's my thing about this i'm really
glad that they just you know did it got
married and i think probably the more
times you get married like yes wedding
planning is torturous so probably gets
smaller and smaller and you just focus
on the love right but there are ways to
get married in a small way that are not
vegas like yeah
could have been a backyard affair vegas
feels very like spontaneous but you
don't like get all glam drazzle dazzle
like prepare
to walk down the aisle to vegas yeah i
do unless there's some sort of history
there right
well i do feel like there's kind of
become like a pr trope recently like joe
and sophie did it first and they did it
best um and most people who do it like
travis and courtney and joe and sophie
jonas is because they need a marriage
license for a um international wedding
so getting one in vegas is like a fun
way to do it so maybe that's what
they're doing
but it does feel like you know a couple
other couples have gotten a lot of press
from this and it's like a fun thing to
do so now like a lot of celebrities are
doing it you know it's definitely a fun
thing to do yeah especially if you're
just doing it for the license because
knowing you're gonna have like a formal
wedding in rome or wherever you do it
and you just need the american license
um i don't know if that's what they were
doing i hope that they don't have a
formal wedding me too because if this is
just the wedding i agree like the more
times you get married the more you
realize like weddings are not even about
the couple it's like
they're amazing but it's kind of just
like a circus sometimes and it's not you
focus on so many other things like
besides the love and the life you're
building with your partner so i do kind
of love this if they just like slip into
married life and and just kind of
skip the wedding phase yeah um so i
don't know if that's what they're doing
or this was just a licensed moment
because that's what happened with a lot
of couples in the past who we we
reported on getting married in vegas yes
that is true anyways i'm very happy for
them and i think a lot of even all this
time people were saying that this is
like a pr thing them being together back
together i didn't believe it i never
really thought that
and i think this confirms that it's not
yeah i mean i love how far would you
take a pr relationship i mean in
hollywood i wouldn't put anything past
anyone but ben affleck and j.lo like
don't need
measures this extreme for pr yeah like
yes being spotted with someone paparazzi
in the park getting a kiss sure getting
married for pr is insane and it's
something someone really thirsty would
do and ben and jlo have been around the
block
gen literally jenny from the block
they've been around the block like for a
while now i don't think they need
something as extreme as this yeah i
agree i don't think it's pr just curious
how far someone might take it and her
hair looked amazing and once again like
chris appleton is the most talented man
in hollywood yeah that's amazing wedding
hair
that's good inspo for anyone she looked
really cute the newsletter of it all is
still like really um
kind of at the forefront of my mind
because it's just
it's just thirsty and you know what it's
literally like kind of extreme for
someone of jayla stature i know and i
just hope that she's getting the clicks
and the subscribers that she's desiring
because it's so
weird weird but like sometimes
celebrities like do these sorts of plays
like even the text me thing you know and
i think you know must be really
successful for them because they keep
doing it yeah that's true maybe this you
know she's building up a subscriber
database she's going to sell her
subscribers in a few years and we're
going to be the ones so sorry people are
sorry 100
left in the dust so maybe she knows what
she's doing i did sign up for her
newsletter like when she got um
engaged and then like i realized i
missed the engagement announcement so i
unsubscribed but she has my data i miss
the marriages right she has my data
you're playing it all wrong 100
okay speaking of love our next story is
that chris evans is laser focused on
finding him a partner luckily for him we
have a list of eligible women right
that's why i wanted to talk about this
because not only do we need to add them
to the list let's go through our current
roster and see if there's anyone who
matches up yes so
chris evans got admittedly candid about
his love life revealing he is laser
focused on finding a partner to quote
spend his life with he's promoting his
upcoming film the gray man and when
asked if he had he had ever been as
intent with a search in his own life he
declared that he was going to give the
interviewer a good answer quote the
answer would be that maybe i'm laser
focused on finding a partner you know
someone that you want to live with he
explained that finding love was
difficult in hollywood i mean look i
love what i do it's great i pour all of
myself into it but in terms of even this
industry is full of pockets of doubt
hesitation and recalibration in terms of
really trying to find someone that you
can really pour all of yourself into
maybe it's about trying to find someone
that you're looking to spend your life
with yes so maybe it's that
okay so chris evans is
41 years old and so hot he's captain
america for anyone who might be confused
with the other chris's
chris
he's also i know him from knives out
like that's really what my um
and what's your number
yes so here's the thing with chris evans
is like he's literally so hot and rich
and talented and i do really feel like
he's one of maybe 10 people in hollywood
who are truly down to earth and like
still connected to like his family and
his roots and is still very humble um
and i think that's what he's talking
about like obviously he can't just go to
a bar and pick up a girl like it's not
feasible so he's like forced to you know
consider people in his own line of work
but that comes with like just a
a hoist of troubles yes he's also from
nanny diaries which we just just watched
such a good movie yes i kind of i'm more
into like
chris evans's early work yeah now he's
mainstream he's avengers he's marvel
this and that and that's not really our
cup of tea he also dated jenny slate
from the polka king oh my god we have
this conversation once a year okay but
let's go into our list of eligible
people now
chris evans and khloe kardashian
i'm obsessed like she's family oriented
i feel like he would really like that
they of course are so famous and rich
but i do feel like at least what i
gather from their show is that they're
pretty like you know
down to earth they're not like these
crazy hollywood thirst monsters like
they really are pretty contained within
themselves yeah no they're they don't
need to thirst because like they've
achieved right more fame than anyone now
what's interesting is that he's been
previously linked to two women on our
list asa gonzalez no selena gomez and
minka kelly so that knocks them off
okay can i just say like minka kelly and
chris evans is like the perfect
relationship but continue what about
chris evans and lori harvey
i think there's too much of an age
difference she's like 23 and that was
the whole point of her and michael b
jordan they said like he was ready to
settle down and she wasn't she's new on
the scene i don't think that's a good
match okay so not chris evans and
addison ray
uh absolutely not that's okay
chris evans and sherry ray
oh my god you know what mama sherry
hmm i could see it and i have kendall
and devon on this list but they have to
come off now they are back together yeah
they were spotted at a wedding i think
that they probably broke up for five
minutes and then changed their mind
which is so relatable
um so no one on our list is really even
though he was like linked to selena
gomez but never
in a kind of tangible way like they
weren't ever spotted together yeah and i
love that couple can i just say yeah but
i think everyone does love there's been
a lot of um chris evans and ryan gosling
press because they're both in this movie
the gray man that had like a big
premiere and ryan has platinum blonde
hair maybe from ken
yes um
and i'm just excited like for ryan
gosling to you know
be back in my life he's so mysterious
he's like are you gonna watch this movie
probably not i mean why not you like
them both what is it about netflix it's
about an assassin who is um obsessed
with tracking down his target and chris
evans is the assassin and the target is
ryan gosling i feel like i watched a
trailer for this movie literally three
days ago does it take place in like a
house
i don't know it's called the gray man
i'm pretty sure i i have i did see a
trailer for it um it's just not my like
type of movie but ryan gosling is just
so interesting to me you know
like the eva mendes of it all like how
they literally just decided like that's
what really what he's what chris evans
is describing is what ryan gosling has
maybe he's been inspired by working with
him on the set and maybe ryan and eva
need to set him up with someone yeah
because they're like really like a
hollywood
fantasy you know they're both so rich so
successful immediately fell in love had
kids and like put acting on the back
burner but are still so a-list because
they don't even care you know it's like
they don't even want it
it's so interesting to me so i feel like
maybe that's what happened like he saw
the love
the foundation that eva mendes and ryan
gosling had and was like that's what i
want yeah i could i could believe it
because what he's describing to this
interviewer sounds like exactly what
ryan gosling is we need to expand our
list you know we just keep writing
people down when they come up in the
news but we really need to
i know think about branch out and think
about
who could be good for this man is emma
roberts single
well no uh she and garrett headlund are
like always on and off okay so she's
busy yeah i think they might be off
right now for sure but there are a
couple i ship like entirely because
country strong obviously garrett hedlon
like would literally i would take bullet
for him so i'm not gonna try and like
ship them with other people because i
really want their happy ending me too
okay well we'll think about it we'll
keep adding oh i have to add chris evans
to the list of eligibles he's so having
this list oh he's already on it that's
really sad
okay he's number two
having this list makes everything so
much easier yeah just more organized
yeah we don't have to keep racking our
brains right
are you ready for even though i feel
like we're literally sitting here
wracking our brains
yes we're always tracking our brains are
you ready for our next story which is a
little more um movie star news disgraced
movie star army hammer has been cut off
from his family dynasty amid financial
woes now this is really interesting
because i didn't realize that he came
from a family dynasty either army hammer
has been cut off from the family dynasty
established by his great grandfather
armond hammer oh is he arm and hammer
no they're like the hammer um
hammer international foundation the
armor
she didn't invent arm and hammer
i know that
that makes sense but there's nothing in
here about argan hammer
so a source told people that his dad
won't help him work won't help him
anymore and he's been cut off so he got
to work and he has been reported um
working in the cayman islands as a
timeshare salesman
while the well had may have run dry for
army following the cannibal scandal that
landed him in rehab the hammer family
continues to live high on the hog thanks
to great granddad armand establishing
himself as a billionaire oil tycoon in
the 1950s with occidental petroleum
running the company from 1957 until his
death in 1990.
who knew yep and now army's dad runs the
company
but he is no longer giving money to army
hence why he could be found
maybe selling timeshares in the cayman
islands now army um went to rehab went
to rehab and it was paid for by robert
downey jr according to vanity fair which
is so beyond weird and confusing to me
because one how the [ __ ] do these two
know each other like i guess everyone in
hollywood just like knows each other and
two from what i've read about robert
downey jr at least on dumois it's like
he's one of like the nicest guys in
hollywood he like he's like one of the
only ones who doesn't cheat on his wife
like he's like this great guy um
and i don't really understand why you
would like pay for
army hammer's like
life his rehab and then allowed army and
his family to stay at his house no i
don't think it was his family i think it
was his ex-wife who doesn't talk to army
anymore and the kids
which is a nice thing the article says a
loud hammer in his family oh the article
i read said it was elizabeth chambers
and the kids but whatever well that
would that would actually maybe kind of
be in line with robert downing jr being
a good guy he wants army to get help and
he's going to pay for the help that he
needs and he's going to help the wife
and kids through
in distress well i like never really um
was like into army hammer or
his downfall because i was never like an
army hammer fan
um but now he's back in the news and we
just this weekend we watched death on
the nile which is the movie that was
like coming out when his downfall was
happening and they like pushed it back
and it was just like this awkward timing
for him so i feel like the movie got no
press yeah it didn't it was weird
i also think it wasn't received well and
it was a fine movie plus like army being
in it like made it weird we watched it
this weekend it was fine it was
it's an agatha christie
tale so agatha you know never flops no
but the way that it was directed was
just a little too long and drawn out but
i always like agatha you know it was it
was a good a fine movie not as good as
murder on the orient so i was just
comparing it to that and it wasn't
nearly as good and some of the acting
was not good and literally love this
woman more than life my israeli queen
gag adobe like she was not good um
so it was like a fine movie but i just
think that what's more interesting about
the movie is that it was the movie yeah
that um army had coming out when all the
allegations against him came out and
they pushed it back and it was coveted
and it was like really drawn out and
then it ended up like not even being
that good yeah or successful which is
kind of i think it would have been
successful if it was a great movie and
like everybody felt compelled to see it
but it was just like you know a movie
that you'll get on dvd yeah maybe it's
like one for us it was like one movie
that when we're all together we could
agree on you know
i think because we liked murder on the
orient so much right so it's like a
movie if like you're home for vacation
or like you're with your parents like
it's like fun for all ages yeah
so but seeing army act was definitely
weird because i think the only thing
i've ever seen him in is when he played
um was he winklevoss was he both
winklevoss yeah i think so
that's so parent trap totally army
hammer let's check his imdb i'm not
super what's also so funny is like then
we also got into timothy xiaomi this
weekend and like they're both call me by
your name
that's what people know both of them
really from i never saw that movie and
that's like what people are really
obsessed with them from yeah
call me by your name the man from uncle
death on the nile the lone ranger the
social network you're right rebecca
mirror mirror oh the um snow white
i wouldn't recall him in it
you didn't with lily collins and julia
roberts you definitely did no i didn't
you didn't
but did you see snow white in the
huntsman yes
kristen stewart no you saw both because
i saw them and it was 2012 we did
everything together no
fine
um more than that nothing that we know
he's just so weird like he he needs to
go and if what he's doing is selling
time shares in turks and caicos or
wherever it was cayman island i think
that's best even though cayman islands
always makes me you know raise my
eyebrows because there's like always
like a legal financial activity going on
there from the states like maybe you
know he's
has an offshore account that does feel
like a weird place now i'm suspicious
again yeah well his attorney told page
six following the reports of him working
in the cayman islands that he could not
confirm or deny the report because army
hasn't addressed it i just quote think
it's shitty that if he is selling
timeshares the media is shaming him for
having a normal job and i think it's
shitty that army hammer was accused of
cannibalism and rape so
i guess we're all just sharing things
that we think are shitty yeah is he
really trying to make
army seem like sympathetic yeah no
because it's like if people are making
fun of him for
selling time shares i don't think that's
what it is though it's just like we
haven't heard from army in so long no
this reminds me remember when that actor
i think it's not that right you know
he's trying to make it that when that
actor from the cosby show was um
somebody like shared on social media
that they saw him working at trader
joe's and everyone was like
and making fun of him and then it ended
up working out for him because tyler
perry was like you guys are so [ __ ]
mean and gave him like an acting job
this lawyer is trying to make it seem
like like that type of situation because
that
like we're shaming army for selling
timeshares like no we're shaming army
for his list of crimes
yeah
yeah that's what we're doing
okay ready for our next story some bravo
drama
yeah tamara judge is returning to the
real housewives of orange county for its
17th season multiple sources exclusively
tell page six quote tamar is thrilled to
come back to the show especially after
feeling the fan love from her stint on
ultimate girls trip she can't wait to
get back in the mix on rahuq and see how
she can shake up the dynamic
now also there's been beef between jill
zarin and tamara because jill apparently
revealed that tamara was going back on
the show and tamara then called jill the
quote thirstiest [ __ ] for revealing
this information that is like not top
secret cia confidential so like why does
it need to be
kept under lock yeah
so the first part of the story with
tamara returning um i don't watch oc and
i don't think there's probably anything
they could do now i thought heather
might have been the thing to get me to
re-watch and i did and it just wasn't
good it's just about timing because oc
even though i was popping off this
season like i was giving birth we both
stopped watching no one i just i didn't
even think and we didn't miss it enough
to go back to it plus noello is a
one-season wonder dr jen isn't coming
back either oh really so that's the
network admitting like this was a flop
don't bother getting invested in these
people so why would i go and watch their
stories if they're not coming back and
now we're going back to tamara and now
we're going back to tower but i just
want to give
a major round of applause to tamara
because
how many seasons was she knocked off for
maybe two at most i think one
and she made it back and that does not
happen it doesn't and people try and
they try and they can't get back they
spend years and maybe after five years
maybe what was it heather how many years
but heather left on her own accord this
never happens and i'm really happy for
tamara that she made it happen and this
i didn't watch ultimate carl's trip part
two crazy in the berkshires but she
obviously put on a hell of a show that
they brought her back and as like a
working housewife and really a
professional housewife like
that's the dream no this is like a and i
think a disgraced housewife fairy tale a
disgraced housewife fairy tale i think
for all the women in this ex-wives club
they all went on this show and i'm sure
every producer was dangling a carrot
like if you do this you'll come back on
your franchise and tamara is the one and
i'm happy for her and when tamara did
get fired i do feel like she got looped
in with some of like the dead weight of
the show because those were were the
girls she was friends with but even up
until the very end like tamara was pot
stirring like she she's a great
housewife and i do think firing her
wasn't the right move i do think firing
like vicky and shannon was the right
move like they were just
still there oh sorry vicky and um
tamara
oh
shana to get fired no she's still on
she's gonna go um i didn't feel like it
was fair that tamara got fired i didn't
feel like she was done like she what's
great about her she literally has no
super bowls like you know she has no
loyalty to anyone she just wants to be
relevant and a lightning rod and she is
yeah to a point that's good to a point
because then if someone is just being
like a
prop or a ploy it's like this isn't real
human dynamics like i can't get invested
so i'm glad that she took a break
because i think a lot of people missed
her and i think even when we were
recapping her last season on oc and
vicki's last season we're like these
people have to go but we're just as
wishy-washy as the rest of them and so
i'm happy she'll be back i don't know if
i'll see what they do with the cast i
don't know if i will still watch i'm
also open to vicky coming back i think
she needed to be humbled in a major way
because she was one of these people who
would go on a room and be like this is
my show you know you're on my show and
and you need to go if you're if you're
saying things like that teresa but then
i'm open to you coming back once you've
learned that this is not your show this
is a cast i actually don't think i'm
open to vicky coming back because i
don't think she
women like her like teresa like vicki
are really not capable of being humbled
i think being fired
is humbling no of course but i think
they would come back and act the same
well let's see i'm open to a second
chance so then there's all this jill
with drama with jill yeah and they're
all going back and forth on instagram
and like to be honest like i don't care
yeah and
i think so the rumor mill was saying
like tamara's coming back and it's
always like these bravo instagrams like
no information before it's like
confirmed and so then jill you know
confirmed it and tamara was mad at her
and it's like it was just giving like a
little like try hard like
forever like for tamara to be like
making a moment you know yeah yeah and
now everyone's talking about that and
not the fact that she made a triumphant
return a triumphant return so she
shouldn't have even addressed it because
she really feel the fire with that
instagram story has any housewife who
has ever been fired not left on their
own according to me heather
fired
made it back
i don't know but if i were to request
someone who was fired we come back it is
phaedra yeah
because
what she did like was fire worthy but
like i do think she's a star but she's
back on ultimate girls so if the network
wants to hire her again or they are
hiring her again then put her where we
need her yeah i mean i guess
who
this was a conversation on ultimate
girls trip like do you believe dorinda
was fired yes
because she says that she's um on pause
and andy told her that and i think andy
even said on what japan's live like he
did say like we're gonna take you off
just for the season not like fired okay
that's still fired but sure like just
like tamara it's technically on pause
yeah yeah i guess that's true if the
pause never ends i mean actually you
could say teddy mellencamp because she's
literally at every soiree in the real
house of beverly hills even though she
was fired two years ago yeah
everyone's doing what they got to do
everyone's doing what they have to do
but i'm happy for tamara because this is
just not something that happens very
often and i often like thought about
tamra's life post-housewives and it just
feels like
her whole life was being a housewife and
she's done it for what 16 years
she she needs it and so honestly i agree
like i am happy for her but i'm still
not gonna watch
we'll see but probably
not yeah i haven't missed it me neither
are you ready for our fifth and final
story which is so twisted in the final
story yeah
ricky martin is denying disgusting
bombshell incest sex crime accusations
ricky martin is denying these bombshell
domestic violence violence allegations
reportedly filed by his 21 year old
nephew it was revealed two weeks ago
that a judge in puerto rico has issued a
domestic violence related restraining
order against the latin pop icon the
alleged victim's name was not previously
disclosed however according to a spanish
publication it is now disclosed under
puerto rico's laws for incest charges
the sentence ricky martin could face is
five decades in prison if the shocking
claims are true
the publication reported the complaint
was made anonymously under law 54 known
as the domestic abuse prevention and
intervention act
this is i mean
the story oh sorry a puerto rican
newspaper reported that this order
states that ricky martin and the person
who filed the complaint so the 21 year
old nephew dated for seven months the
alleged victim claimed that ricky didn't
take their breakup well and has loitered
near the petitioner's home at least
three times according to the report so
they were in a consensual incestual
relationship for seven months i guess so
and
ricky martin's attorney marty singer
said unfortunately the person who made
this claim is struggling with deep
mental health challenges ricky martin
has of course never been and would never
be involved in any kind of sexual or
romantic relationship with his nephew
he said this is not only untrue it is
disgusting we all hope that this man
gets the help that he urgently needs but
most of all we look forward to this
awful case being dismissed as soon as
the judge gets to look at the facts i
mean it's so disgusting like just the
for the base of this case like stalking
an ex is so [ __ ] up and then you add
the element of the fact that his ex
might allegedly be his nephew
it is so disgusting
i i literally can't no i literally can't
the base of this case is that he maybe
dated his nephew right that and then of
course stalking an ex is never
what you want
but
if this is true it's disgusting if it's
not true when the nephew is claiming
that this happened it's disgusting no
matter how you slice it right this story
is horrible yeah and i very much um
will be keeping up with this story
because the two possible truths are so
different
like let's say his statement is
uh
ricky martin's statement is totally true
like this is a mentally ill cousin or
whatever of ricky martin and these
claims are so false it's so disgusting
and defamatory but on the other side of
it if he literally was having a
relationship with his nephew and then
all of that afterwards stalking and
abusing
so [ __ ] disgusting so i'm actually
extremely curious because it's easy to
say you know as a celebrity with you
know access to amazing lawyers this is
all untrue right so that's what everyone
does right i want to see facts i would
like to uh be a juror like i need to
know yeah well hopefully with the facts
we'll keep you posted
twisted you don't hear from ricky martin
in so long and all of a sudden he maybe
allegedly is dating his nephew no and
honestly my condolences to
all the gay men in america because ricky
martin is their icon their leader and
their idol and it's it's tough to hear
that your idol dates his nephew like it
is very tough pill to swallow i imagine
i imagine so i'm thinking of all of you
um but in other news you know ricky bird
ricky ricky martin probably needed to
unburden himself and maybe if he had
written into the toast he'd be feeling a
lot better because today's monday and we
are doing unburden yourselves which is
our um segment on mondays that we call
unburden yourselves where you can write
in that's true to unburden yourselves at
gmail.com
um and you can tell us something
embarrassing that you did over the
weekend something that
haunts your dreams something that's like
a chip on your shoulder that you're just
carrying you need to get it off your
chest and we're here to take that burden
and to place it on the floor for you and
kick it we're gonna make you feel better
about it so everyone who wrote in this
week thank you for being vulnerable and
if you want to get on unburden
yourselves plural gmail.com
this is a um
hold on let me check i have three okay
this let's start let's start light okay
okay hello jackson claude and brazilians
drastic rise and to draw some rounds and
shrouds and brass and shazam brass and
dragons i need any bryce for this
segment i have to invert it myself
because you girlies are the only ones
who will understand okay i was stopped
at a stoplight for a while and i quickly
checked to instagram and i watched the
story of claudia giving jackie the baby
book of um claudia builds a bridge with
for bruno i was laughing so hard and
dying at jackie's reaction that i ended
up near-ending the car in front
rear-ending the car in front of me when
i cried on the phone to my dad he asked
me if i was on my phone of course i lied
because that's so embarrassing but just
want you guys to know that i love you
and i'm never looking at my phone while
driving again i really am glad that you
shared this with us so that we could
take an opportunity to say get the [ __ ]
off your phone when you're driving like
these roads they're so dangerous when
you're driving on the highway yesterday
there were so many signs like your lap
this is this
could be your last and it's like nothing
that you're doing even claudia's stories
while so important so so so important
nothing is more important than like you
driving safely and it's not fair to the
drivers around you so like if you are
one of these people who even touches
your phone while you're driving stop i
completely agree it's one of my biggest
pet peeves i won't drive with someone
who's on their phone of course not i
would sooner get out on the side of the
road and call an uber a safe driver i i
agree it's the dumbest thing you can do
and nothing on your phone is important
no text you're sending even if you're
telling someone where you'll be nothing
stop it no and also
to this girl who wrote in like i'm so
glad you're okay and let this be a
lesson like a warning from the universe
like it was such a small fender bender
you're totally fine the other person is
fine stop being on your phones when you
drive it is literally so dumb and
there's really nothing going on unless
you're like
like an emergency room doctor with a
beeper there's no reason you need to be
touching any technology when you
drive
there's no reason whatsoever and i'm
glad that this person had this
experience that she could write in so we
could use this as an opportunity to
remind you and if you're that person who
uses your phone and you think it won't
happen to you stop stop it's not fair to
the other drivers on the road it ain't
it
all right but we're not trying to shame
you and just let this be a lesson
in caution
next up
hello claudia and jackie i did the most
mortifying thing ever yesterday and even
if you don't read this hopefully i'll
just feel better writing it in i'm a
summer intern working mostly remotely so
yesterday i was listening to music while
doing my work my boss called me out of
nowhere via microsoft teams so the call
rang on my computer and my phone i
answered on my computer and then right
round by flow ride i started playing on
my phone a few seconds before i could
turn it off and it was not on mute i was
listening to early 2000s music and
that's what came on but now i'm so
embarrassed and i just wasn't listening
to taylor swift like i usually do anyway
now my boss thinks i'm a freak that
listens to florida in my free time
that's a particularly bad song oh i
disagree i actually feel like it's
better that you were listening to write
round which is a
a hit a class no but everything it's
like disgusting
you spin my head right around right
around when you go down when you go down
down
i think i think it's a song about
[ __ ] boss probably can get down to
florida more than he could to taylor
swift and maybe he's like oh simpatico
can't wait to hit up happy hour this
with this girl
i think it's fine yeah i think it's fine
too also um it's just so important to
realize like nobody cares about you and
i'm not saying that like in an insulting
way like you're going over this in your
mind but like literally your boss deals
with like a million people like he
literally or she like probably doesn't
care you know no and so you listen to
music while you work
at least you're working you know it's
not like your tv was playing and you
were watching the new season of
something that's true you know like
i don't think there's anything wrong
with this so your phone played a little
music like who's your boss the gestapo i
think i think she's more focused on the
song itself not the fact that song
played because it is a particular okay
but at least that's a song that
everybody knows it's not like you listen
to like niche pornography music yeah
that's true actually i just don't think
he's thinking about it and neither
should you you know agree to you it's
like this big thing but to him it's just
like one of the many things he has to
deal with at work or she i don't know
why i keep assuming his boss is a hate
like i feel like she said he i'm
toxically patriarchal i feel like she
was like he
no she just kept saying my boss thinks
i'm afraid
this was a test and we failed my boss
called me out of nowhere my boss thinks
i'm a freak i got no pronouns and i
assumed he and that's on being toxic
and that's why i'm not supporting women
supporting women in the workplace no i
don't know literally like i'm so toxic
so someone cancel me cancel me
you're fine girly don't worry about it
you're totally fine
all right next up
this is the third and final one jackson
claude my favorite my favorite iconic
duo it's time for me to set this burden
down i found out my boyfriend of three
years who lived with me was cheating on
me so prior to making him move out i put
itching powder on the inside of every
pair of his boxers i folded them back
exactly as they were and place them back
in the dresser i hope when the itching
starts he thinks something is wrong with
him and sits down with the girl he
cheated with now his girlfriend and
talks about testing for an std love it
we love a creative um really harmless
you know it's not like you put something
toxic in there it's not like you put
crabs in his underwear right now like
it's a joke
yeah this is perfect actually i actually
respect the creativity the ingenuity and
i feel like as long as there's no
permanent side effects or anything on
what is itching powder didn't even know
that why would they make a powder that's
just supposed to make you itch probably
for pranks okay for pranks it's like
it's like fart in a can like why would
they make that for pranks okay assuming
there's no
indications i think the punishment
matches the crime i completely agree and
it's just a nice way for you to like
sleep well at night knowing like you got
taken advantage of but then you made
things right yeah i love this for you
and guess what he [ __ ] around and he
found out 100
and that's what we call justice justice
yeah and it's nice to like some people
like take pranks way too far like i see
it on tick tock all the time like even
if the person deserves it like sometimes
people take pranks too far and i think
that this is the perfect level of prank
yeah and i'm proud of you and i respect
your creativity and ingenuity and
there's no burden you need to on here
but it probably feels good to talk about
it like something that you kept to
yourself yeah yeah yeah love that for
you
um so that was on burden yourselves
unburden yourselves
gmail.com that was our show
our show hours
not not theirs oh no no no never they
would never and they will never but they
wish they
[Laughter]
that's not the right words no i started
singing high school i know and then i
took it to sister act you have to when
jesus watched when jesus they couldn't
wash my sins away
oh have a great day
thank you for listening to the morning
toast
thank you so much for listening to the
morning
stress and breath and shine brass and
stress and breaths and stress and brass
and stress in ah bryson
[Music]
how does it start like the
oh happy no but just like
[Music]
two
[Music]
okay
now we'll let you go happening crab day
thank you so much listening to the
morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcasts can be
found out spotify itunes stitcher public
radio ire radio cast box all the places
wherever you listen to podcast find us
some more chosen leave a five star view
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are
have a great day we'll see you tomorrow
goodbye
[Music]
you